so hello oslo
or when i first got told i could speak
at nbc oslo about six years ago i
thanked jakob for letting me visit
denmark for the first time
i nearly didn't get to that conference
um
so
who here saw the opening keynote two
days ago it seems like a world away yes
so that was mikko hypenin from f secure
talked about unicorn hunting
and what i noticed was very early on he
said he'd spent 30 years
with the company and has had an
incredibly um
interesting life and has enjoyed it
thoroughly
this key note is almost an antidote to
that because i have not worked for the
same company for 30 years
um so this is all about the choices i've
made
it's called
two roads diverged in the wood
who knows this poem
has anyone heard it who's ever seen dead
poets society the film
you see that's why i couldn't do jokes
about dead poet society because not
enough people have seen it
so in this poem
whoops i've gone one too far sorry about
that um
that conclusion is i took the one less
traveled by and that has made all the
difference
so it's a poem by robert frost the road
not taken
and in dead perch society it's all about
an english teacher teaching kids at a
private school
about poetry and about the wonders of
life
uh
and that really stuck with me that it's
important that
the most attractive the most fast way of
going through life is not always going
to be the best
so that's what this talk is about it's a
ex
a kind of explanation of how i've
managed to get into
i've had my career and all the jobs i've
done so i've done quite a lot of jobs so
i decided to just rattle them through
while i talk
because the choices you make in life are
often seem quite random
but they greatly kind of affect where
you get in life
and looking back i've realized that i've
made some pretty good choices in the
past i didn't realize they were
particularly good choices at the time i
probably didn't do them for exactly the
right reasons but they've made my life
as a developer fun enjoyable and
ultimately much more rewarding
so i'm going to take this whistle stop
tour for how i got speaking on a stage
in norway in front of you guys in front
of the audience up there
who are on the second floor now
via
social inadequacy which is always a geek
thing when you're young
resigning from jobs earning
significantly less money at times
being cajoled into talking at user
groups finding out to hang out with cool
developers like you guys and just chat
to them
i ended up being a microsoft mvp and i
ended up talking at ndc and getting away
with wearing loud suits like this at
developer conferences
so how did i start
it's kind of being in the right time at
the right place
and i hope to show that
you have the ability to change your life
it's your choice where you end up
working
don't always make the most obvious
choice or the right choice
and it's not about being the best
developer ever
it's about being the best developer you
can be and the best person you can be
and that's a much more interesting thing
to try and achieve
and you'd be wise to ignore the
conference thing right talking at
conferences is actually quite stressful
at times
um i didn't go to many sessions for the
last few days because i've been making
sure that this will work and trying to
practice it
so instead of that why don't you just be
a really good developer in your
workplace be awesome there contribute to
some open source projects mentor other
developers
make their career paths really good and
be an authority on subjects you like
that's your road to find
but where did i start
i grew up in the countryside in the
north of england i happened to live next
to
friends who decided to build their own
computer from a kit brought in from
america
and
they also had one of the first hundred
apple macs ever brought into the uk so i
amazingly was used to the idea of mouses
and pointers and windows way ahead of
the time that a pc ever got that and
they sold me their secondhand zx81
which was a home computer in the uk made
by sinclair
and when i went to high school
obviously when you start high school one
of the things teachers might ask is what
do you think you want to be
as a job and there's people who want to
be trained drivers or doctors or lawyers
maybe one of them wanted to be a teacher
but normally at school when you're 11 no
one wants to be a teacher because they
look at the teacher and go what a shadow
i don't want to be then
and i said i wanted to be a computer
programmer not a developer because
developers didn't exist they were
computer programmers in those days
and pretty much the whole class went
what the hell is a computer programmer
so
i was destined to be a computer
programmer
so i ended up programming a zx81 and a
bbc micro which was the posh computer at
the time
uh i found that i
was limited by just doing bbc basic so i
taught myself i bought the advanced user
guide for the bbc micro
and on that cover you can see things
like assembly
language 6502 assembly ldy stands for
load the wide register
and i taught myself 6502 assembly
language
i went off to sixth form college where
you do the exams before you go to
university
and they told me please don't do a
computer science degree if you're
already doing assembly code you don't
want to do a computer science degree
you'll be so bored
so i took the easy route i did physics
maths and chemistry
which is a very geeky sciency thing to
do i avoided doing a fourth a level and
i decided that maybe i might want to be
a journalist in the future as well so i
decided to do typing exams
so i'm actually officially rated at 40
words per minute on an electric
typewriter i have a certificate to prove
that
touch typing is really handy where later
in life when you do become a developer
it's quite cool and i did a media
studies course as well and that avoided
me having to work too hard let's be
honest
but i had to choose where to go to
university or college
and certainly my mother went i think you
should try and get into oxford or
cambridge which is what any parent or
school would like you to do
and i decided not to apply for physics
at cambridge
because in my
you know young life i just
looked at cambridge and they said if you
do physics you get a bachelor of arts
degree
not a bachelor of science degree all
subjects were bachelor of arts and i
said they don't count science as serious
because they still consider it an art
i'm going to go somewhere that's going
to give me a bachelor of science i
should have gone to cambridge because
that's where all the computing guys were
well they weren't in oxford
but i did actually go to oxford for a
job interview
it was one of four universities i tried
to go to i was applying to
they always interview you at oxford
separate in person
uh you were meant to do an entrance exam
i was a cocky northerner who said when
they asked me why i hadn't done the
entrance exam i said
because i think you're like every other
university and they don't make me do an
exam
so clearly i didn't get into oxford
um but i already knew i wanted to go to
this place called brunell in london
brunel university
and i wanted to go there because it had
a radio station and it did something
called work placements so i was going to
get to work in three companies while i
was doing my degree
and i could see what the real world was
like
so i went no to the dreaming spires of
oxford and that gothic architecture and
that wonderful buildings
to brunel university
which
corbusier would have still had a problem
with
this is the most brutalist concrete
architecture going and it still looked
like that's about 10 years before i went
there and it still looked like there
back then
but they had work placements
so it was good
so i've done the standard thing that
everyone does in in the kind of middle
class upbringing that i had in england i
went to school i did my own levels i got
a levels and i went to university
it was a really standard thing
i hit there as a stereotypical geek
poor social skills scruffy pale
programming until two in the morning on
the computer with instead of talking to
people properly
and that's pretty much the background of
quite a lot of developers i feel
there's far too many middle-aged white
college educated men in this room
compared to what they should be
so it's important that we recognize that
and change that and allowing people to
have different career paths and flexible
career paths is actually part of that
so my first real choice
i decided
that i wanted to work in television
it may surprise you given the clothes
i'm wearing at the moment that i was
quite keen on television
um i used to watch a lot of it um even
though there was only three four
channels when i was growing up
so one of the work placements i went to
the first one
uh was a company physics department in
industrial research and development and
they made cans and
they made the they're the guys who
invented the fact that a drinks can goes
in at the top slightly
instead of being straight
which by the way saves a tenth of a cent
per can in aluminium which when you're
selling that much coke matters quite a
lot to your costs
so that's how they were successful in
business but while i was there i saw
this magazine computing
and it had a job
for a real developer an actual real job
at the bbc computer graphics workshop
somewhere that did graphics for
elections and the weather and the sports
results
so i thought i'll write to them and see
if they've got any work placements
whether they'd consider me i'll bypass
the workplace workplaces officer at the
university who normally gets you your
jobs
and i wrote to them and they said
actually we do do work placements
we normally go to a different university
kingston university is where we get our
students from we've got one for next
year but you can come in two years time
so i went for my possibly coming two
years time went for a job interview
um
one of the things i had to do at that
job interview is explain to the head of
hr in the television department
what a mouse was
in terms of a computer
just someone who'd never seen one
that's actually quite hard to explain
there's a wire coming out there's this
metal ball bearing underneath
and it kind of has rollers in it and it
moves something on the screen but you're
not used to graphics so you probably
don't have a clue what i'm talking about
but i got the job
and it was helped by the fact that i'd
done this media studies course at a
level instead of trying to do a fourth
exam
and it was my choice chance to work in
television and i loved it absolutely
loved it there's no chance i wasn't
going to work in television
because it clearly was an exciting place
to be for me
it was definitely an exciting place to
be
so how am i going to get there i
finished my university degree
um i don't know if anyone's tried to get
a job in television
it's kind of got a lot of people wanting
to get jobs
even then it was quite hard to get into
so i was having to wait around i decided
that i hadn't had a proper holiday for
four years
i realized to everyone in this room who
works
they only get a couple of weeks at any
one time on holiday but as a student you
normally had long holidays over summer
we never got them because of work
placements so i decided to be unemployed
for six months and just get money off
the government and off my parents
clearly because they were the ones
subsidizing my lifestyle at that point
but i refused to get a job that wasn't
in television
uh and i was quite determined about that
i went to quite a lot of job interviews
and there was even possibly a job
interview at the police met the london
police service it's called the
metropolitan police
but when you're in these interviews i
think they realize that if you were ever
going to be given a job by the bbc you
would leave so they didn't want to
employ someone who was likely to leave
which is a fair point because that's
exactly what i would have done
so
i eventually did get offered i actually
got offered a couple of weeks work on a
general election from a small company
based inside sky television
and that was through someone who'd
worked at the bbc computer graphics
workshop when i'd done my work placement
so because i'd chosen this weird
university that had hideous architecture
i got a work placement that allowed me
to get a job in television
and then they thought actually he can
code he's quite good we'll have him uh
we'll have him at 2 000 pounds a year
less than two years earlier when i was a
student on a work placement
so it's a good job i had savings because
that was the only way i could survive
living in london at that point
and we created the first in-house
weather system for sky news
doing the little suns and rains on a map
and temperatures and having clouds come
in and show you where the rain was going
to be
and that was written in visual basic 1.0
which is a challenging thing to have
done running on windows 3.1
and actually that also led to becoming a
network engineer a breakfast tv channel
as well so i ended up being
a swi a weird dual life of being a
programmer developer in the morning for
four hours getting on a train for 30
minutes to go to a different building
where i was a network engineer
and i knew how to configure file servers
and do networking but i did virtually no
programming
so
eventually
i
got a enough of a
permanent role at the tv company the
breakfast tv company that i could afford
to just work afternoons so i actually
left this small company that was inside
of sky tv
one of the designers graphic designers
at sky tv had commented that
my boss could only relate to things that
had batteries in them
which explained his kind of demeanor and
attitude and i thought it was time for
me to move on the same designer by the
way gave me one of the most
something in the uk we call a backhanded
compliment
and what she said was i was the most
normal computer person she'd ever met
that did not mean i was a normal person
i couldn't quite realize what she was
saying
but the really nice bit is i resigned
told my boss i was leaving and he said
oh were you going to work and i said
nowhere i'm just going to get up at 12
every day
easily get up and just go and work four
hours in the afternoon and he said well
if you've not got a job you could carry
on working for us and i think you've
missed why i'm leaving
right i'm leaving the job
and it's really
an important moment because you only
have one life
you'll be spending more time with people
at work than you will with your friends
or family at home
like genuinely you spend more time with
them
so if you are working in an environment
you like
or you will don't want to work with
idiots
then don't leave and go somewhere else
if you have the ability to do so i know
i'm in a privileged position where i was
university educated and i have skills
and i have that option but if you have
that option seriously take it
obviously now i manage people and i have
developers who resign
it comes into my head
that they may not to want to work with
idiots
and who is the idiot in my company
and i'm normally worried it's me
so
i then became full time i went back to
sky and actually worked for them
directly in the end left my job as a
network engineer decided i was
definitely going to be
a programmer
actually a senior developer at that
point and then run the team inside of
sky doing computer
graphics but i got head hunted this is
in the days before linkedin linkedin
they'd find you they'd know what you
were doing they'd have a history
and these days headhunters
used to have to know people inside a
company who knew people inside that
company that they thought might want to
leave and they could approach
so i got this phone call saying do you
want to work at this interactive tv
company
so interactive tv was like applications
on a set-top box and it's really fancy
and it was the big thing at the time
because people didn't have broadband
there was no data on phones so the only
way people kind of got to that kind of
application or the internet was through
their set-top box
so i thought this sounds really good
center of london it was going to be
energetic it was a start-up
it lasted seven months before the
company went bust right so i left a
secure job at sky
where if i'd have waited another year i
would have had share options cashing out
worth about 20 000 pounds
but i went to this tiny company in the
middle of
of london one of the reasons
that apparently i got offered the job i
found out from the headhunter later
is when he interviewed people he'd
interviewed him on the phone and if they
were good on the phone he'd then bring
them in in person and have a chat with
them
and he had to have a way of categorizing
people
and what he did was categorize people as
domestic
short-haul or long-haul
so his comment was
if i was sitting next to this person on
a plane
and i was talking to them for the
journey
would you only want to fly a domestic
flight from oslo to stavanger
or
a short haul fight maybe to madrid
or somewhere like that or would you want
to go long haul to new york having to
talk to that person for nine hours
the amazing bit was i was categorized as
long haul which if people have met me at
geek beers or the party may or may not
be the feeling you got so your mileage
may vary and it may be much shorter than
long haul
and you may think that wasn't very lucky
that wasn't a good choice i went to this
company seven months gone bust but it
was really good because i started
working in the center of london instead
of being on the outskirts sky was 10
minutes walk from my home
but it's just where people live it's not
where anything happens
i got given a crazy job title of
broadcast architect which doesn't really
exist because i just made a title up to
fit what i was going to do
i learned more about startups and vc
funding and things like that
and that whole process of having a job
title made for me being employed by a
company who said we're not sure
what exactly you're going to do but we
need people like you in our organization
which gave you a huge amount of
validation that was ego stroking big
time
to be head-hunted and told we're making
a job for you because we think you are
worth employing
but it went bust
so what did i do i thought i know
i chatted to a colleague
who worked at the breakfast tv company
he did it services he hadn't got any
software
the ability to write his own software so
we'd form a separate software arm
and i would work for myself
have anyone here said you work for
yourself
do you really work for yourself or do
you work for your clients
and the answer is you work for your
clients or customers
right so you don't really work for
yourself the interesting thing is you
get to pick who you work for so you get
to pick the clients and customers and
you can avoid the idiots
so
it is quite nice
i took a 50 pay cut in order to start
that company
um
but you know i'm a founder of a tech
company it's just after the dot-com boom
so what job title do i give myself chief
technology officer because clearly i can
just have any title i want because i own
the company
a cto should really understand business
as well as the technology i clearly
didn't
but that didn't matter always remember
that when you deal with a cto from a
company if it's a really small company
in the refounder they may not have all
the cto credentials you might expect
they'll be very enthusiastic though and
probably quite interesting
importantly i was still in the centre of
london
and i could go to this newly started
user group the london.net user group
which was advertised in something called
the msdn flash email an email you got
once a month to tell you what was
happening in the world of microsoft
because you didn't go to websites you
waited for the email to turn up to read
about what was happening
and
and it said hey this is a user group and
it's just two streets away
and this is where i met someone called
ian cooper
now this is a photo from a developer
conference
you can tell it's a developer conference
because there are five white
college-educated middle-aged men
all right
there is a developer of concern
in this photo it's this man
that is ian cooper
it's that man
now if you don't recognize ian cooper
and you may have heard of him because he
does talk a lot at ndc and do workshops
he doesn't look like that anymore he
looks more like this
so
he left the world of finance and banking
and said
i'm never going back and to prove it i'm
going to change how i look and how i act
and my whole you know really cool
the irony being that by now the world
has moved on enough he could go back
into banking
because that doesn't stop you being a
banker anymore which is quite funny
so but it got me into
the ian cooper said you could do a talk
about the user group just a little one
on mobile development because you seem
quite keen on moving mobile development
so i did a talk a couple of talks only
ten minutes
eventually he said
you know we're doing this conference
developer developer developer day the
first one that had launched
and he said
i think you should do this talk so i did
it on an rm i was writing because as
every developer knows what you need is a
new framework
because you're not going to use someone
else's and virtually every developer
thinks they could write an orm so so did
i
um i'm not sure i really did i did try
and make it open source but never gave
it a push
um but i got picked it was cool
uh you can see me at this conference
uh just there
with my user group t-shirt uh oddly
enough
while ian was looking smart in those
days
i looked like that
i had much more hair and several more
chins
um
so i think what happened was i got my
hair cut short ian grew his beard and we
kept the average follicle length in the
developing community in london at the
same average right
and maintained it but the interesting
thing is i thought i've gone spoken at a
conference i can't believe it this is it
i got selected i've got my validation
and then one of the organizers published
the statistics on how many talks have
been proposed how many rooms there were
and the way you got to talk at ddd1 was
to submit a talk because that's how many
talks they had for the number of rooms
so it had nothing to do with how good i
was right that's the realization however
by talking at those conferences and i
improved and i got better at speaking
uh and it gave me more confidence
and it helped me when i'm running my own
company because it's sales skills that's
what present presenting is so it allows
me to do sales better to companies i
ended up hanging around with something
called an mvp from microsoft because
some of these guys were microsoft mvps
and oddly enough i kept talking at user
groups and eventually they nominated me
to be an mvp
and then eventually someone asked me to
talk at a paid conference in london ndc
london and i ended up standing here on
the stage giving a keynote to you guys
in the middle of a pandemic
and
if you don't enjoy this keynote
you need to talk to ian cooper and tell
him he should never have got me to speak
at london.net user group
so it's his fault
but i were we closed down the company i
co-owned we got money at the end of the
day and i did that partly because i was
about to have apart from there was a
recession in the tv industry
uh or recession in the country which
means less advertising as soon as
there's less advertising tv companies
get less money so they pay less to
production companies to make tv programs
that's it we get less money
so we closed that company down and i was
having children
or just about to have my first daughter
and thought it would be good to be my
own boss properly and have time at home
because my partner was still a video
editor at gmtv
and she worked long shifts she worked
four night shifts 12 hours one week
three day shifts the next week 12 hours
each there she worked saturdays and
sundays and things like that so someone
was going to have to look after the kid
at certain points it would be just me it
wouldn't be
like being there at the same time
um
also
so you go i'm going to work for myself
i've got a little bit of money from the
company
and then you realize
however small a child are and they're
tiny right children when they come out
this big right
they need a room that big to store all
the crap you need right it's like a huge
amount of stuff that you need to buy to
support a kid
so i suddenly realized that yes i do
need work i've got a contact at the user
group who
i said do you want to work for me just a
couple of days a week so within one week
of having my child
having you know started my own company
to decide i can work for myself within
one week i was already working between
christmas and the uh for someone in
order to make sure i had the money to
start that company properly and get it
going and the other thing i needed to do
was buy an msdn license which costs a
huge amount of money it was the most
expensive thing you could have to buy
for the company at the time
there was no free one like biz spark in
those days so it was going to be two
thousand pounds which was a huge amount
of money
um but i found a loophole
i found if you became a microsoft
partner you might get a free msdn
license
but you had to be a silver tier but that
meant you had to have 200 points it's a
microsoft marketing thing and one of the
ways you could have 200 points is to
have this logo on your software
this was a point at which dot net was so
big in microsoft's head everything
had.net on it even windows server at one
point was about to be called windows.net
server
and so
i needed to load software onto
microsoft's site to prove i could write
a soap web service because the future
was going to be soap
xml whistles
that's where everything lay i could put
this logo on my website that ended me
200 partner points that got me a free
msdn license
in between my daughter being born at
about quarter past 10 in the morning on
the 20th of december and me going home i
went home and i collected all the stuff
to pick up my partner and daughter and
bring them home for the first time and
tidy the house up i also spent one and a
half hours
using verisign to code sign some code
upload it to microsoft and apply for my
logo that's what i did in between my
daughter being born and her coming home
for the first time
frightening
um so i went along with that and i
worked for myself and i
eventually had another child and i went
i can't work at home
with children because they come home
from nursery and they want to be with
you and you're a bit snappy because
you're halfway through coding
i thought i want a
separation of work
and home
so i started renting an office up the
road
from some financial advisors in the acu
botanic gardens it's a very nice place
to work
these offices and the really nice bit
about working there was also everyone
was self-employed there's about 12
people in that office there was museum
designers market researchers charity
workers the two financial advisors
and if it was nice weather and sunny and
pleasant to be outside
you'd go down the pub
because we all worked for ourselves so
clearly we could do whatever we liked
eventually my other half worked out this
is what was happening
and said
i want to stop being a video editor
working night it's killing me
because it's really hard work i mean it
takes days for you to recover from
working nights and get back into being
daytime and that by the time you've
recovered your back working long shifts
on the day
and i'd like and she wanted to see the
kids
so i went right
i've got to stop mucking about
however there was another lack of
customers at that point in my life
so i tried to go back to sky tv
and it was interesting because i had a
general election coming up
and they said we need extra resources
you've worked on general elections it's
changed a bit since you were here you
know it's been about six seven years but
you know
you know your stuff you can help us
write it
obviously i had all this child care so i
told them that i'm only available a
certain amount because i've got to pick
up the kids from nursery and i look
after them at the weekends
and so i went off onto
this trip
to work at sky again this is my commute
into work by the way through richmond
park and i'm happily going up the road
which is a metaphor for working at sky
you see and this deer runs across the
road which is we've got a rehearsal and
it's going to be this saturday
and this is on the thursday and i said
but i can't do saturday that saturday
because i'm looking after my kids right
the other half works and they went can't
you get her to call in sick
no
no because that's wrong right you know i
said i couldn't work here on that day
and
it got to the point where this junior
manager
said to me
i'm going to terminate your contract he
basically said it's either the job or
the kids
right that's what he did to me and this
is a warning to anyone who manages
people who gets into that point where
they say
the job is more important than your
children
i mean just look at this
more important than that
some crappy election at sky tv it wasn't
um
so i just left it
and that was one of the best choices i
made
personally it was really nice to know
that push comes to shove i would tell
someone to stick their job over and
above my children if it was going to
affect my children
but more importantly i end up in a
better job
i i was at another
user group old.net beers after a
conference in london
chatting to someone they were at a music
startup mp3 downloads
i'd been a records manager at the
student radio station at brunel i really
liked music i'm into bands i've listened
to new music all the time still i
especially i kind of pick up new bands
all the time
and so i went to this interview
and it was a proper start-up the cto had
broken his leg skiing the week before
and had a plaster cast on the table in
front of me because it was it was quite
painful
the head developer or senior developer
at the company a new zealand guy said
he'd seen me give my ddd talk
two months ago and it was really good
and i thought i just have to not blow
this interview because i really want
this job
and within a few months the head of
development went back to new zealand
anyway
and i became the head of development for
this mp3 startup
and then
eventually
i actually became permanent when i
became permanent i negotiated into my
contract that i was always going to
leave at two on a wednesday afternoon to
pick up the kids take them swimming go
to scouts go to cubs and do all that
kind of thing
i also negotiated that i would have 10
days
per year to talk at user groups
conferences or go to the mvp summit
this is amazing the amazing bit is that
when you join a company that's when you
can negotiate those kind of things into
your contract
it's really hard later to do that but
it's really important to think about
that when you join a company and they
were really good about it all and i got
the proper startup buzz again and i was
working with a fantastic development
team both at the back end they were
fully agile and there was a php team
using a system called magento if
anyone's ever used that it's an
e-commerce platform
they managed because it was music and we
had the whole of warner emi and so can
you believe i'm in a job where we have
the entire of warner music emi and sony
on hard drives in our office
cd quality level
uh unbelievable
but that's millions of items that we
have to put in a shop but they made
magento work so well
that magento tried to poach my staff to
work on the product to get it to that
scale
which is an amazing place to work
but eventually
the cto left we interviewed for new ctos
i said my input was whatever we do we
don't interview this one
uh we don't employ this guy
they employed that guy
that guy said you know all this tdd this
tests
it really slows your development down
doesn't it
and you do you really need a build
server
can't you just release it straight from
visual studio
no
um so we had a difference of opinion on
how you're meant to run a company
uh and how are you meant to develop
software
so i started looking elsewhere because
that's what you do when
you decide you don't want to work with
that idiot it's a different kind of
idiot but he was annoying
because he was going to cause me to make
compromises in producing good quality
software and i didn't like that
so i started looking elsewhere
guess what
i was still going to the london.net user
group chatting to
ian cooper
by now this guy called dylan beatty who
wore this hat
was coming to the user group and there
was a guy called toby henderson who i
i'd been at conferences with and shared
bedrooms in order to save money clearly
because we
wanted to make our conferences as cheap
as possible
and he was working at huddle
he just hired toby about six months
earlier and i went huddle sounds
interesting
a proper startup in the center of town
it's at something called silicon
roundabout so this is the sunny uplands
of the startup world this is where it's
all happening this is fields of golden
wheat
um so i'm going i think i need to go how
do i get to talk to ian cooper
um
rather you know in a more private space
than just after a user group and um i
spotted on twitter that they were going
to this restaurant called hawksmore
and
i don't know how many of you have been
to london and visited hawks more but
it's quite a nice restaurant
i had no idea what it was i knew it was
something to do with steaks
thought yeah we're going to have a steak
i'm steaking chips have a chat something
like that
when i got there
they said yes come because someone
dropped out i looked at this board on
the wall
and what they actually have is huge
hunks of meat in kilograms that you buy
right and they roast in an oven they're
fantastic by the way
but the gar weed come late so
the smaller weights had disappeared and
it was only the expensive bigger weights
and i looked at dylan and toby and ian
and they're going i think we should have
this wine and this one they were picking
wines off it i looked around this table
and thought
you know what
those three people are single and don't
have children
like they're used to spending 90 pounds
on a meal
this is going to be a phenomenally
expensive thing to
explain to my other half when i get home
i'd better get a job out of this and the
fortunate bit was i got a job out of
this
so
that was a good explanation to the other
half the next day who'd always been
quite good at allowing me to go to
conferences and user groups because she
realized how that actually helped my
career
and she should be at home at the moment
watching this on youtube
all right
and one of the nice things was
although i got the job via ian who never
got a referral bonus because he was
going to directly manage me and he
wouldn't be allowed to get a bonus for
recruiting someone
but the joy of working for huddle at
that point was you got to meet this
woman
oh a recruiter
i don't have huge
sympathy for recruiters in most of the
time but this person is fantastic
michelle flynn
she helped on board me into huddle she
helped negotiate the four and a half
days that i had at the previous company
and she said what you don't want to do
is work extra hours
you want to take that as time off you
want to work on a 90
salary
because then people can't phone you on
that half day and expect you to do work
they can't expect when they ask you to
work late on other days it's not like
you're already working late to make up
that wednesday so it's fine
and she was quite right it was one of
the best pieces of advice
didn't mean i took a hike up by the way
to go to huddle yet again third pay cut
in my career
but she has always cared about
developers she's helped run user groups
she actually talked to developers for
years before ever employing them and
waited till she noticed they were ready
to leave and that's an amazing ability
to have she now has changed her life
career to be a life coach and only does
a tiny amount of recruitment
but she's incredibly talented and i
one of the reasons i had such a good
time at huddle was being brought on by
her
so
what are going to be the things that i
would advise you well what did i learn
that may be useful to you not all of
this will be useful to you we all go
through different paths we all go on a
different journey so only some of this
might be applicable
but i think one of the things i learned
was that i work for people and projects
not companies
so i definitely work want to work
somewhere where i enjoy being with the
people
that i believe in the product that i'm
working on
uh and i don't have
one of the guys at sky when i went back
said you should be proud to even have a
sky
work pass on your you know
on your on your hanging around your neck
and i didn't understand that because
that wasn't me i'm proud to work in that
department i'm proud to do the graphics
i'm proud to help other developers do
their best work
so when i'm working for an mp3 download
company it's fantastic because i'm a
music guy
you know i really like getting into
music when i worked in tv it was great
because i watched so much i still watch
far too much tv i have set up boxes full
of with the hard drives are bursting uh
i can't deal with a streaming service
because i could stream for six months
off my own hard drives as it is i've
legitimately recorded stuff not even
stuff that i've got off bitcoin
um and i've never always gone for the
most money
and this may be
is this something i learned no because
even at the age of 17
i saw my brother come back from
university and my brother was always
smartly dressed he died as her he was
really cool you know he tried to be up
with the latest trends and things like
that
i
not so much
really not so much and i watched him get
up at five in the morning
to go and work on farms and pick
lettuces
where a tractor would go through the
field and he would be lying flat that
far from the ground picking lettuces in
order to earn money and my conclusion
from that
is you should never want money enough to
have to work for it
right because i don't want to do that so
instead i'll buy less clothes
not have my hair cut as often all sorts
of things i would do to avoid having to
pick lettuces at six in the morning in a
field in lancashire
and dickens wrote
some famous words charles dickens in
david copperfield
and this is you may have heard this
before but annual income 20 pounds
and you'll expend it to 19 pounds 19
shillings and sixpence
which to go into the modern world means
you have 6p left over at the end of the
year
result is happiness
if your annual income is 20 pounds and
your annual expenditure is 20 pounds
nothing and sixpence
then the result is misery because you're
now having to own money to people
so a strong believer that happiness
today still
doesn't mean you have to earn the most
money
it's nice to be comfortable it's nice to
be able to buy stuff that you like
and have a nice house but you don't need
to have the biggest house the fastest
car any of that
it really isn't going to make you much
happier and i'm hoping
that post-pandemic people realize that
more than ever
but there is that danger we're just
going to flip back
and go back which i hope we don't
and the other thing i learned
was to build a savings buffer so if you
ever work as a contractor or a
consultant
even an employee
if you can save three to six months
salary
so that if you had to leave a job the
next job is one you pick rather than one
you have to go to you will be much
happier
because i got forced into position where
i went back to sky where i needed the
money and it was not a happy experience
and when it's right to concentrate on
the family do it
right
you only get one chance to see your kids
grow up like seriously that's why my
partner wanted to give up her job so she
could watch her kids grow up properly
because she was missing out on that
so
it's got a lot better
we actually in the uk have paternity
leave we had no paternity leave when i
had kids
and my boss was an absolute sod and gave
me no paternity leave it was me
i didn't give myself paternity leave at
that point i was working within days
the kids
because we didn't i didn't earn the most
money i had to share a room for 14 years
they probably moan about that quite a
bit at the moment still even though
they've got rooms to their own now
but that'll go they'll forget about that
but the fact that i was there going on
holidays camping all the stuff that i
did do because i was actually there will
be much more important
although apparently they forgot all the
times that i stood at the side of a
netball or hockey pitch in the freezing
snow over winter watching them get
injured
apparently they can't even remember
being injured less the fact that my feet
were freezing
but that didn't really affect them and
go to user groups and community events
right if you stay just in your own
company
or you don't really go into forums or
join like an open source project you're
meeting the same people all the time and
you're all working with the same tools
and maybe occasionally someone brings
new stuff in
but if you go to user groups you'll meet
people from 20 30 companies
and they're all doing different things
and they've got different ideas and
different ways of working some of those
will be really cool
some of those you might bring back to
your company
and that'll be really good because you
can change your company to be where you
want to work instead of having to leave
your company and go somewhere else
that's even better if you can manage
that
because you're going to improve it for
everyone including your fellow workers
i know that contradicts family life
my comment about family life going to
user groups because you tend to do it
out of hours out of work hours but it's
really valuable and really worthwhile i
think and that london.net user group got
me my first contract work and it got me
speaking at user groups and the
conferences and everything and ending up
here
don't
probably do all that
you know
so and the other thing
apart from you should always be nice to
everyone wherever you work
when you do
work somewhere
there are three people you should be
especially nice to
the first one is the security guard
this is the guy who lets you in the
building and sorts out how you park your
bike under the building for me in the
bike store
and keep them friendly because they're
really nice people if you get to know
them
the next one to get you be friendly to
is the receptionist
because they're the person who gets your
amazon parcels and make sure they end up
on your desk
plus they probably give you the spur key
when you forget your door pass and
that's the pass you need to be able to
get to the toilet without borrowing the
pass off for your colleagues
and finally whoever in an account
accepts your invoices or does the
payroll
because that makes sure you make their
life easy and you get paid on time
but otherwise
i hope you can equally have an
interesting career and going down these
interesting roads that looks like it's
sunset but that was the middle of saying
middle of the day in december last year
on 100k ride
and i hope your journey through life
will be as interesting and as
pleasurable and i hope this may just
have bring you one or two things that
you haven't thought about before
that actually mean you have a really
enjoyable and successful development
career
thank you very much
[Applause]
you